>> PETERSON GOT THE NOD IN EACH
OF THE LAST TWO GAMES
ANHE END
GETTING A REDIRECT ON THE HIGH
SHOT WAS GETZLAF AND OFF THE
BLOCK.
>>>> ON THE
LINE FOR BOTH OF THESE TWO TEAMS
.
IT IS FUN TO.
THE FINAL SECONDS.
SAID THAT IN AND HE MOVES ITT T
FOR FOR THAT LIKE SCOPE
LUNDERSTROM GOT A GOOD SICK ON
HIS D-THE MAC.
HES
DRIVING THE CENTER LANE AND HE'
ALL HE'S GOT TO DO IS PLAY THE
STICK DOWN .
THE SECONDARY ASSIST WITH THE
GOAL ON HIM.
VICTOR ARVIDSSON STICKS IT AHEA
FOR  FIRE THAT HIGH OFF THE
BOARD.
COULDN'T COVER IT.
BACK BY THE DUCKS.
IT LOOKS LIKE ISACAC
ROY IT LAYS IT ACROSS AND THEN
CHANCES.
HAD THIS
SEASON.
AGAINST THE KINGS IN L HE
TRIES GO HIGH AND A QUICK PASS
SEASON AND THE KINGS GO ON TOP 2
-0.
IN DRIVE FINALLY GET TO HIM.
GAUDI'S CAREFUL WITH HE MOVED T.
FOR YOUR
LINEMAN WHO ARE MAY BE THE SHOT
ADRIENNE KEMPE AND HE JUST KIND
OF WIRES THIS ONE YOU LINE.
THAT HIT BY TWO UP THAT ARE TAN
TOGETHER AS THE PUCK GOES THE L
THEM ALL YOUR OFFENSIVELY.
AND THIS IS WHATEQUIPMENT.
HE GOT CAUGHT IN THE BLOCK AND
COULDN'T GET IT OUT.T. ON
THE ICE.
NO CENTER LANE DRIVE FOR THEHE